méxico se enfrenta a su peor sequía en
décadas la falta de agua afecta a las
granjas y los animales mueren de sed
como estamos viendo por el camposanto de
las vacas flacas a raíz de la sequía que
estamos pasando de la presa hasta ya
tiro baja es a raíz de eso que son
muchos atascaderos las vacas pues llegan
a tomar agua y se quedan atascadas los
pescadores también se ven afectados y
muchos han decidido irse
y nosotros como pescadores aquí pues
estamos batallando porque no hay no hay
este pesca suficiente para sostener
nuestras familias y algunos compañeros
optan por salir a buscar trabajo
a la ciudad a mediados de julio el
gobierno mexicano declaró la emergencia
nacional y anunció iniciativas para
evitar que grandes empresas como
coca-cola y heineken extraigo en tanta
agua en el norte también se han
establecido topes de agua en los hogares
de la ciudad industrial norteña de
monterrey pero para los agricultores no
es suficiente pero nosotros como
productores pues no tenemos la capacidad
y menos que tenemos unos años con poca
agua
nos estamos estamos de escape
descapitalizados necesitamos el apoyo en
las últimas semanas las lluvias del
monzón americano han proporcionado
cierto alivio en chihuahua pero sólo el
10 por ciento de las presas de méxico
están ahora llenas julio fue el segundo
mes más caluroso en méxico desde 1953
según el servicio metereológico nacional
con temperaturas que alcanzaron los 45
grados celsius en algunas zonas